ja willkommen zur aktuellen Sitzung
wir werden uns heute mit einem ganz
spannenden Thema befassen nämlich
nachdem wir wieder unser begriffsnetz
uns angeschaut haben mit dem Thema
Gerechtigkeit ein ganz wichtiges Thema
wir werden ein bisschen die politische
Philosophie hineinblicken politische
Philosophie kann man auch zu praktischen
Philosophie zählen und ich glaube der
wichtigsten Begriff der politischen
Philosophie ist der Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit ne also wenn man über
Gesellschaft und Gesellschaftsformen
Gesellschaft Strukturen Gesellschafts
Probleme philosophiert dann geht es
letztendlich darum ob darin
Gerechtigkeit realisiert wird und mich
persönlich interessiert immer auch die
andere Seite der jeweiligen Phänomene
die wir uns anschauen also mich
interessiert zum Beispiel wenn wir uns
mit dem guten beschäftigen das machen
wir in der nächsten Vorlesung also
morgen dann interessiert mich natürlich
auch
und Sie bestimmt auch das Böse und wenn
wir uns mit Gerechtigkeit befassen dann
könnte natürlich auch das Thema
Ungerechtigkeit eine Rolle spielen mich
persönlich interessiert aber mehr des
Phänomen des Neides wir haben hier mal
kurz über diskutiert man eine spannende
Diskussion
und zwar die Frage ist
neidgerechtfertigt oder überhaupt was
ist eigentlich nein und mich
interessiert hier die Frage die möchte
ich mit Ihnen gemeinsam diskutieren auch
mit den Zuschauern und Zuschauen auf
Youtube dann unten im Diskussionsbereich
wie verhalten sich Gerechtigkeit unten
Neid zueinander also ist Neid
gerechtfertigt Neid ist ja ein Gefühl
und eine Einstellung die sich immer
zwischen verschiedenen Menschen
vielleicht auch Menschengruppen
vollzieht und darüber wollen wir heute
dann auch noch diskutieren sie können
sich jetzt schon ein bisschen Gedanken
machen
ja wie immer das begriffsnetz ich spüre
mal ein bisschen vor wenn sie natürlich
alles auswendig bei so langen
Weihnachtsferien ist es klar dass man da
natürlich das Betriebsnetz anschaut und
jetzt kommen wir hier plötzlich ganz
unten rechts zu einem neuen Bereich
sollen und sein darauf geben wir heute
noch mal kurz genauer ein und dann
politische Gerechtigkeit habe ich jetzt
unter das Thema moralisch gemacht
also ich finde das politische
Gerechtigkeit oder Gerechtigkeit
überhaupt
zum Bereich der Normativität zählt das
sehen Sie hier und ich glaube dass man
das in diesem Kontext diskutieren muss
also Normativität
und ich glaube auch dass man
Gerechtigkeit im Kontext der moralischen
Normativität diskutieren kann und dann
haben wir wie schon gesagt hatte einen
kleinen Gegenbegriff ist nicht genau
dagegen Begriff gegen Begriff wäre
natürlich Ungerechtigkeit aber ich
glaube dass wir über den Begriff des
Neides oder das Problem des Leides sehr
viel Aufschluss bekommen können erhalten
können über das Problem der
Gerechtigkeit aus philosophische
Perspektive sie können sich schon denken
was demnächst da noch alles hier in
diesem freien Eck rechts unten alles
reinkommt
wir werden hier den Begriff des Guten
noch kennenlernen der kommt natürlich
dann hier rein geben das moralisch und
den Begriff des Bösen der kommt
natürlich mit so einem widerspruchspfeil
daneben also das erwartet uns noch
rückblickend möchte ich noch mal auf
David hum hier eingehen also der
Beziehung den haben sie schon in anderen
Kontexten kennengelernt ich mache oben
rechts sind auch ein Video den Link rein
zu der Sitzung wo es um die Frage ging
ist es vernünftig Moral im
moralisch zu sein als anders gefragt
widerspricht unmoralisches Handeln
unserer Vernunft und David jung hatte da
einen skeptische Auffassung vertreten
Sie sich an den Ritz im kleinen Finger
den ich ähm deren Vermeidung des
Vermeidung ich den Untergang der ganzen
Welt vorziehen könnte ohne dass es ein
Widerspruch gäbe das sagte David jung
und er hat natürlich auch zu anderen
Themen was gesagt unter anderem zum
Problem
das Verhältnis ist von sein und sollen
also wie kann ich Normativität das
sollen begründen da hatte ein ganz
bekanntes Zitat das lese ich jetzt hier
nicht mehr vor das haben sie alle schon
gehört ich möchte nur darauf hinweisen
dass das Thema sein sollen Fehlschluss
ein ganz wichtiges Thema es geht um das
Verhältnis von sein und sollen die
Folien finden Sie alle auf Ilias schon
wie immer und er sagt plötzlich werde
ich damit überrascht dass mir anstatt
der üblichen Verbindungen von Worten mit
ist und ist nicht kein Satz mehr
begegnet in dem nicht ein sollte oder
sollte nicht sich fand es geht also ein
Wechsel in philosophischen Texten nicht
nur ein philosophischen Texten auch in
anderen Kontexten findet dieser Wandel
vom sein zum sollen an ab und Zustand
und das ist ein problematisches
Verhältnis und er sagt dieser Wechsel
vollzieht sich unmerklich das heißt wir
machen uns da häufig was vor und er muss
aber dennoch begründet werden das also
ganz wichtiges Thema wie kann ich das
Verhältnis von sein und sollen begründet
das nennt man den sein sollen Schluss
wenn wir vom sein auf sollen Schließen
von deskriptiven Sätzen auf normative
Sätze ohne diesen Übergang zumindest mit
guten Argumenten zu begründen das sagt
der Beziehung hier auch gleichzeitig
sagt er muss ein Grund angegeben werden
für etwas das sonst ganz unbegreiflich
scheint diese Frage worin der sein
sollens Fehlschluss besteht das ist
natürlich eine gute Frage für den
Fragetyp eins in der Klausur ne also was
versteht man unter dem sein sollen
Fehlschluss geben Sie ein Beispiel dafür
haben wir das eigentlich im Fragenpool
drin Hammer okay also damit können Sie
eventuell rechnen mit seiner Frage ne
okay ähm jetzt möchte noch mal
Wiederholung geben wir können also nach
diesem sein sollen Fehlschluss nach
dieser Theorie dieses Fehlschluss ist
nicht unmittelbar zumindest von
deskriptiven Prämissen auf normative
Prämissen oder Konklusionen
Sätze schließen wir brauchen
zusatzargumente zusatzgründe die diesen
Schluss gültig machen und diese
zusatzbremsen die diesen Schluss gültig
machen die müssen natürlich auch schwach
normativ sein sonst auslosen sein kann
ich kein sollen folgern nur können diese
zusatzbremsen etwas verständlicher sein
die können zum Beispiel nicht ganz so
kontraintuitiv sein nicht ganz so stark
sein ich habe schon darauf hingewiesen
es gibt bestimmte Begriffe in der
Philosophie traditionell die so eine
gewisse schwache Normativität besitzen
und die sich deswegen sehr gut dafür
eignen so ein sein sollen es Übergang zu
leisten ich habe schon mal einen Begriff
erwähnt das ist der Begriff der Vernunft
ja wenn man sagt das ist vernünftig dann
hat das immer so eine schwache
Normativität oder wenn wir sagen du bist
unvernünftig dann ist darin ein Vorwurf
enthalten nämlich eine Ermahnung du
solltest dich nach den Regeln der
Vernunft richten du solltest dich nach
der Logik was auch immer jetzt Logik ist
er sollte sich daran orientieren also
Vernunft hat eine selten deskriptive
Seite etwas ist logisch nachvollziehbar
es hat aber auch eine normative Seite
und mit solchen Begriffen wie von Luft
ein anderer Begriff ist der Begriff des
Lebens das wird mit der morgigen
nächsten Vorlesung kennenlernt der
Lebensbegriff der hat auch eine schwache
Normativität zu kann man ihn zumindest
interpretieren also mit solchen
Begriffen Vernunft leben die natürlich
auch immer ein bisschen unklar sind das
bringt die Sache mit sich mit solchen
Begriffen kann man versuchen diesen
Übergang von seinem zum sollen zu
bewerkstelligen ich bringe ihn jetzt
gleich mal ein Beispiel das habe ich
habe ihn auch schon mal gezeigt
sollen wir die nicht menschliche Natur
schützen also nicht nur uns Menschen das
kann man mit dem kategorischen Imperativ
recht gut zeigen nach kann kann
natürlich auch wieder kritisieren aber
sollen wir zum Beispiel nicht
menschliche Tiere schützen oder sollen
wir sogar
Pflanzen schützen sollen wir das
klimaschützen sollen wir den Golfstrom
schützen sollen wir das Ozonloch
also kleiner machen die Atmosphäre
schützen da wird schon schwieriger und
jetzt kann man versuchen so eine
lustvolkerung von sein auf sollen
herzustellen die Natur ist organisch
verfasst sie besitzt eine Ordnung also
sollen wir die Natur schützen das wäre
so ein typisches Problem das Übergangs
vom sein soll aus seiner deskriptive
also beschreibenden Prämisse oder einen
Satz die Natur ist organische fassen das
würden die meisten würden das zu geben
natürlich ist die Natur organische fast
da gibt's irgendwelche Zwecke das der
Vogel baut sein ist alles ist irgendwie
Gleichgewicht ne das ist ja wohl klar
was auch immer jetzt Ordnung und
ideologisch ist muss man da hingestellt
sein lassen und jetzt kann man aber nur
problematischerweise darauf auf die
schützenswürdigkeit der Natur schließen
das ist natürlich normative Aussage ja
wenn ich sage die Natur soll geschützt
werden dann ist es nicht mehr nur
deskriptiv aber jetzt ist die Frage wie
kann ich von dieser ersten Prämisse von
dieser Beobachtung dass die Natur
organisch ist und zwar nicht nur unsere
Natur sondern eben auch die Natur die
sie hier draußen sind der Bodensee ich
weiß nicht was könnte ich beliebige
Dinge vorstellen liefern dann drauf
kommen soll dass das schützenswert ist
oder dass wir das irgendwie erhalten
soll oder nicht zerstören soll oder was
auch immer und jetzt habe ich da
versucht dieses Argument zurück
konstruieren also man muss dann
gewissermaßen eine
Brücke bauen zwischen dieser Prämisse
die deskriptives und der Konklusion
deswegen habe ich jetzt hier ziemlich
viel Platz gelassen und die muss man
jetzt auffüllen mit zusätzlichen
Prämissen die diesen Schluss diesen
Übergang dann gültig werden lassen also
man könnte sagen die Natur verfolgt
eigene Zwecke eine Natur die Zwecke
verfolgt setzt Werte und jetzt sehen sie
mit dem Begriff des Wertes kommt schon
ein schwach normativer Begriff ins Spiel
klar weitermachen kann sagen eine Welt
mit Zwecken oder Werten natürlichen
Werten ist besser als eine Welt ohne
solche Zwecke oder Werte
und dann kann man daraus schließen die
organische Natur ist schutzbedürftig
weil sie Werte hat und Werte sollen
erhalten werden weil Welt mitwerten
besser ist als eine Welt ohne also folgt
daraus wir sollen die Natur schützen und
das wäre jetzt so eine Möglichkeit
dieses diesen Schluss gültig werden zu
lassen natürlich kann man da treffen
drüber diskutieren und das machen wir
jetzt auch ganz kurz in einer Pause
ja wir haben gesehen in der Analyse
dieses Arguments dass man jetzt hier mit
diesen zusätzlichen schon schwach
normative Begriffe einbringen muss zum
Beispiel Begriff des Zwecks die Biologie
braucht den Begriff des Zwecks nicht und
den Wert betrifft schon gar nicht und
Wert ist natürlich im Verhältnis zu
Begriff des Zwecks schon deutlich
stärker normativ ne Geld hat einen Wert
Werte sollen geschützt werden und so
kommt man dann mit dieser Argumentation
schnell auf die Schutzbedürftigkeit ob
eine moderne Biologinnen moderner
Biologe dieses Argument akzeptieren
würde sei dahingestellt das muss uns
jetzt erstmal nicht interessieren
dann sind wir auf die Uhr eingegangen
von dem stammt der Begriff des
naturalistischen Fehlschluss ist auch so
ein Begriff kann man gut in der Klausur
Verlangen zu klären das natürlich wieder
in Frage Typ 1 ja
wir können den Begriff des Guten bzw gut
bzw gut nicht definieren wenn wir etwa
Glauben gut durch das Prädikat angenehm
definieren zu können dann unterliegen
wie einem naturalistischen Fehlschluss
naturalisticalacy ich überspringe das
jetzt ein bisschen er sagt einfach gut
kann ich definiert werden und es ist ein
Grundbegriff ist ein nicht mehr weiter
definierbare basale begriff er ist keine
Definition fähig das Wort gut der
Begriff gut und er kritisiert John
Stuart Mill der sagte gut behauptet so
viel wie begehrenswert
das ist seine sein Versuch gut zu
definieren
versucht das und nur sagt es geht nicht
und ihr kritisiert er jetzt mir
begehrenswert meint einfach das was
begehrt werden sollte oder was begeht zu
werden verdient das heißt das was gut
ist
zu werden das was man begehen sollte
weil es eben gut ist und damit wie
gesagt das begehrenswert bedeutet in
Wahrheit das was zu begehren gut ist und
damit hat er das Wort gut den Begriff
gut schon vorausgesetzt ja mit diesen
begehrenswerte hat also gerade nicht
definiert durch angenehm oder
begehrenswert sondern hat es eigentlich
immer schon vorausgesetzt ja
das ist also keine wirklich gute
Argumentation das geht in eine Art
Zirkel rein man man versucht das jetzt
endlich zu zeigen oder herauszubekommen
was man eigentlich immer schon annehmen
muss das ist ein Zirkel jetzt gehen wir
weiter jetzt kommen wir zum neuen Thema
der heutigen Vorlesung und zwar um
Gerechtigkeit ein ganz starker Begriff
und natürlich auch ein normativer
Begriff des können Sie jetzt schon so
langsam sehen ne und dann sagt das ist
gerecht das ist ungerecht dann werden
wir
Weise die sicherlich von der Weise
unterschieden werden muss wie wir davon
sprechen dass etwas moralisch gut ist
oder moralisch schlecht ist ja aber
darüber diskutieren wir gleich möchte
ich Ihnen dieses Bild hier zeigen und
möchte mit ihnen da auch ganz kurz ein
bisschen darüber diskutieren was wie sie
dieses Bild beschreiben würden ja wir
haben gesehen es handelt sich um eine
Allegorie eine Personifikation einer
abstrakten eines abstrakten Phänomens
eines abstrakten begriffsergerechtigkeit
Justitia wir haben gesehen es gibt hier
die Waage die abwägt ermittelt auch
Urteil natürlich Urteilskraft ist auch
was ganz wichtiges das Schwert was eine
Konsequenz da steht und die Augen die
Unparteilichkeit darstellen sollen die
sich nicht blenden lässt von
Äußerlichkeiten sondern die
ins Zentrum zielt und die Sache wirklich
durchschauen möchte jetzt kann man sich
verschiedene Fragen stellen was ist
eigentlich Gerechtigkeit oder vielleicht
politische Gerechtigkeit was macht unser
Handeln gerecht natürlich immer auch im
Gegenteil was macht und seine ungerecht
welche subjektive und intersubjektiven
Strukturen fördern oder beeinträchtigen
Gerechtigkeit
wie verhalten sich Leid Ungerechtigkeit
sondern dass es eine Frage die mich
jetzt in letzter Zeit sehr beschäftigt
hat aber bevor wir diese Fragen klären
wollen wir wieder in die Diskussion
übergehen und wollen uns mal fragen was
eigentlich Gerechtigkeit ist bzw wie sie
Gerechtigkeit definieren
also wir haben sehr zurecht gesehen der
Begriff ist Waage und auch die
Vorstellung was ich dahinter verbirgt in
der Gerechtigkeit ist nicht so eindeutig
wie vielleicht der Begriff des moralisch
guten behaupte ich jetzt mal hat der ist
irgendwie klarer
wir haben auch gesehen dass der Begriff
des Rechts und damit in eine Beziehung
gebracht werden muss zumal schon Justiz
hier das Wort use in sich enthält den
Haus des deutschen Gerechtigkeit recht
also recht Ungerechtigkeit verhalten
sich zueinander wie genau das muss
natürlich noch zeigen also man kann
jetzt sagen Gerechtigkeit ist eine
Tugend darauf haben sie hingewiesen ganz
auch schon sonst schon gehört eine
Drogen und zwar nicht irgendeine Tugend
sondern es ist eine Kardinal druckend
diese ganz wichtigen Tugenden
Gerechtigkeit ist man könnte
Gerechtigkeit auch als politisches Ideal
bezahlen sie sehen ich habe sie alle
schon antizipiert was sie hier gesagt
haben ne ähm und jetzt kann man sich
fragen wie verhalten sich Gerechtigkeit
und Rechtfertigung zueinander das finde
ich auch ein ganz spannendes Thema wäre
sich rechtfertigt möchte im Recht sein
möchte sagen dass das was er oder sie
getan hat gerecht war also
Rechtfertigung ein ganz wichtiger
Begriff gehen wir erstmal auf
Gerechtigkeit als Tugend ein
Gerechtigkeit als tun eine
erstrebenswerte Charaktereigenschaft
Gerechtigkeit wird im Kontext andere
kardinaltone diskutiert sie können sich
überlegen welche anderen Tugenden ist
noch gibt nicht präsentieren die mal
Mäßigung
Tapferkeit
und Weisheit sind so andere ganz
wichtige Tugenden es gibt natürlich auch
noch andere Tugenden darüber kann man
diskutieren aber die werden häufig es
gibt auch Vernünftigkeit oder wird auch
manchmal angeführt sie sehen die sind
natürlich auch schon schwach normativ
manche Tugenden werden dadurch gebildet
dass man die richtige Mitte wählt dass
man praktisch Mittelweg zwischen zwei
Extremen ähm nimmt das ist zum Beispiel
der Tapferkeit der Fall tapferkeit ist
die gesunde Mitte zwischen Feigheit und
Tollkühnheit ne das heißt man kann auch
versuchen
Tugenden oder Normativität jetzt im
falschen Aristoteles durch den richtigen
Mittelweg zu bestimmen der eben extreme
vermeidet also austragiert halten also
sie sehen es sind Charaktereigenschaften
Haltungen war als normative Begriff muss
man sagen Gerechtigkeit ist ein
relationaler Begriff da hat der
kommiliton jetzt Recht darauf
hingewiesen wenn ich nur alleine
existiere macht es wenig Sinn von
Gerechtigkeit zu sprechen weil
Gerechtigkeit immer nur dann auftritt
als Problem das zu erstreben ist oder
vielleicht als ideal wenn ihr mich
vergleichen kann und zwar mit jemand
anderen und zwar in der Regel mit
jemanden der sich mit mir auch
vergleichen lässt
ich könnte jetzt zum Beispiel Prinz
Harry beneiden oder sagen das ist nichts
Gericht jetzt habe ich schon Neid
eingebracht der bekommt für sein Buch
glaub 20 Millionen Dollar so ein Buch
was er nicht mal ganz alleine
geschrieben hat er hat ihn ja noch
jemand geholfen dabei und ich bekomme
vor einem Buch
auch wenn es philosophisch ist nicht so
muss dafür noch was zahlen damit es
überhaupt gedruckt wird das ist doch
ungerecht so so könnte jetzt
argumentieren sie sind jetzt jetzt
beginne ich schon zu rationalisieren und
zu argumentieren und versuche mein
Gerechtigkeitsbegriff hier stark zu
machen und jetzt kann ich immer sagen
kannst du dich überhaupt mit dieser
Person vergleichen um dadurch um die in
der Folge dann auf das Prinzip der
Gerechtigkeit zu beziehen man könnte man
sagen da gibt's gar keinen wirklichen
Vergleich Punkt du vergleichst die Äpfel
mit Birnen und kommst dann zu einer
Konklusion dass du ungerecht behandelt
hast ja also Gerechtigkeit erfordert
immer dass ich auch irgendwas direkt
vergleichen lässt um anhand dieses
Verhältnisses klar zu urteilen ob
Gerechtigkeit erfüllt ist oder nicht
aufgerechtigkeit verwirklicht wird
erzählt werden kann oder nicht ob es
ungerecht ist oder ob es gerechte das
heißt du musst immer die Umstände auch
berücksichtigen um einen wirklichen
vergleichsverhältnis herzustellen zu
können anhand dessen ganz klar und
eindeutig entschieden werden kann ob
etwas gerichtet umgerechnet ist das
heißt man braucht immer eine hohe hohe
Grad von Vergleichbarkeit Situation ist
ganz wichtig bei der Gerechtigkeit liegt
auch der Gedanke von Gleichheit zugrunde
die bewahrt oder hergestellt werden soll
natürlich Gleichheit muss man immer in
den jeweiligen Kontext und sehen es
müssen Situationen Kontexte der
Vergleichbarkeit gegeben sein damit ich
überhaupt sinnvoll Aussagen über
Gerechtigkeit treffen kann oder nicht es
macht keinen Sinn mich als Autor mit
Harry als Autor zu vergleichen was zum
Beispiel die Einkünfte macht keinen Sinn
ja obwohl man sicherlich auch gewisse
Argumente dafür entwickeln könnte dass
man doch bitte schon andere Autorinnen
und Autoren die doch auch wichtige
Bücher schreiben doch mal bitte besser
entlohnen sollte ja sie sehen man kann
da immer wieder ein Argument raus
entwickeln kann wir können jetzt und das
ist ein ganz wichtiger neuerer Begriff
wir können Gerechtigkeit über den
Begriff der Fairness näher bestimmt ich
komme gleich näher drauf zu sprechen auf
den Begriff der Fernet das ist ein
Begriff der im 20 Jahrhundert der
zweiten Hälfte des 20 Jahrhunderts vor
allem in der angelsächsischen Debatte
Übergewichtigkeit stark Zentrum gerückt
ist Fairness wenn Sie dieses Wort hören
fern ist dann denken sie bestimmt auch
sofort an Fairplay habe ich recht gehabt
oder nicht ich denke jedenfalls dran und
ich finde es gar nicht so eine schlechte
Idee ich glaube dass man
sportlich wenn man es die Sache
sportlich sieht auch sehr viel über
Fairness vielleicht nicht direkt über
Gerechtigkeit aber über Fairness
herausbekommen kann sportlich etwas zu
nehmen darüber kann man es gleich noch
ein bisschen genauer Gedanken machen
über das sportliche und das Gerechte
amphäre wir wollen uns natürlich auch
gleich mal noch Gedanken machen was der
Unterschied in ihren Augen zwischen
Gerechtigkeit und Fairness ist was sie
mit fernes kommentieren darüber
diskutieren möchtest gerade noch hier
durchbringen
ungerecht können nicht nur Personen oder
ihre Handlung sein man sagt selten das
ist eine ungerechte Person man ist dazu
verleitet wenn man auch sagt dass eine
unmoralische Person aber in der Regel
meint man eigentlich die Handlungen von
einer individuellen Person aber es
können eben auch und das immer im Sinne
dieser intersubjektiven Dimension die
wir auch schon anhand des Themas der
Person kennengelernt haben individuelle
und kollektive Person die Gerechtigkeit
der Ungerechtigkeit als Prädikat als
normatives Prädikat kann sich eben auch
auf soziales Strukturen und
Institutionen beziehen ja ich kann zum
Beispiel
gewisse historische Strukturen soziale
Strukturen kritisieren weil da
vielleicht bestimmte Menschen
diskriminiert wurden systematisch also
Diskriminierung ist auch so ein
Gegenbegriff an einen Begriff der
Entspannung zum Begriff der
Gerechtigkeit steht ne also so kann man
eben auch sich diesen Begriff annehmen
und jetzt gehen wir gleich über aufs
das ist diese bekannte politische
Philosoph vielleicht eine der
wichtigsten politischen Philosophen der
Jüngere Zeit und der hat eben ein Buch
geschrieben mit dem Titel Gerechtigkeit
als Fairness und auch noch ein anderes
Buch mit dem Titel eine Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit ist theory of Justice und
wir wollen jetzt aber erstmal bevor wir
uns mit John rolls näher beschäftigen
uns alleine Gedanken machen über den
Begriff der Fairness was verstehen sie
unter fair oder Fairness
ja wir hatten gesehen John rolls ein
Philosoph der zweiten Hälfte des 20
Jahrhunderts die hat eine ganz
einflussreiche Theorie der Gerechtigkeit
entwickelt dabei ist auch auf dem
Begriff der Fairness eingegangen aber
dabei lieber nicht stehen hat jetzt
versucht Gerechtigkeit folgendermaßen zu
definieren zwei Bedingungen gestellt
erstens jeder mal so jedermann soll
gleiches Recht auf das umfangreichste
System gleicher Grundfreiheiten haben
das mit dem gleichen System für alle
anderen verträglich ist ui das kommt
natürlich hier auch schon wieder gleich
gleich rein ja
und zweitens soziale und wirtschaftliche
Ungleichheiten sind so zu gestalten dass
A vernünftigerweise zu erwarten ist dass
sie zu jedermanns Vorteil dient und die
sie mit Position und Ämtern verbunden
sind die jedem offen stehen so bestimmt
jetzt
John walls in seinem ganz bekannten Werk
und wichtigen Werk eine Theorie der
Gerechtigkeit als serious justice
Gerechtigkeit ja
also es geht hier auch um System und er
bringt auch den Begriff des Rechts ins
Spiel ja ein Anrecht haben da haben wir
wieder gesehen Zusammenhang von recht
Ungerechtigkeit Grundfreiheiten
und auch sozial und wirtschaftliche
Ungleichheiten
müssen gestaltet werden natürlich hier
wieder wirklich das vernünftigen auch
ein bisschen vage was ist jetzt hier
vernünftig und der Vorteil ist natürlich
auch ein Begriff der sehr
offen ist die man so oder so bestimmen
kann ja die jedem offenstehen das ist
auch ganz wichtig Position und Ämter
stehen jedem offen und nicht nur
Menschen aus einer besonderen sozialen
Schicht ja das gibt es ja auch noch
viele Staaten wo nur Menschen in
bestimmte Positionen kommen wenn sie aus
einer bestimmten Schicht kommen und dass
das vielleicht nicht ganz gerecht ist
leuchtet ein jetzt möchte ich mit Ihnen
aber noch eine Diskussion machen und
zwar
möchte ich sie jetzt fragen ob Neid
gerechtfertigt ist also stellen sich vor
sie bewerben sich auf eine Position die
sie gerne hätten
sie bekommen sie nicht und sie glauben
sie haben das Gefühl dass sie dafür auch
geeignet gewesen sein
ja ist neidgerechtigt wenn ihr
gerechtfertigt wenn jemand sagt die
Person Verdienst aber nicht wir haben
gesehen eine große Mehrheit sagte nein
ist gerechtfertigt wie können wir das
jetzt verstehen natürlich müssen wir
auch auf das den Begriff des Gericht
fertig Seins eingehen wir müssen
unterscheiden zwischen Gerechtigkeit und
Rechtfertigung also was ist der
Unterschied wie verhalten Sie sich die
zueinander Gerechtigkeit Rechtfertigung
Gerechtigkeit würde ich jetzt sagen ist
ein Begriff der eine Objektivität da das
ist objektiv so und eine Rechtfertigung
ist immer aus einer subjektiven
Perspektive
und jetzt scheint mir sozusagen aber
darüber können wir wie immer diskutieren
dass die neidische Person sich wenn Sie
eine andere Person etwas leidet auf das
Prinzip der Gerechtigkeit bezieht das
ist wohl unstrittig eine neidische
Person
die Frage ist ob eine neidische Person
weiß dass sie neidisch ist ich glaube
sie weiß es nicht sind sie würde immer
bestreiten dass sie neidisch ist
wenn Sie sich bewerben auf eine Position
sie bekommen die Position nicht und
sagen zu der anderen Person oder sagen
über die andere Person ja also das waren
jetzt halt connections ja dass sie es
bekommen hat und ja
da dass das Spielen andere Motiv in der
Rolle
das und dann bekommen sie gesagt du bist
doch nur neidisch
dann würden sie oder ich würde dann
sagen nee ich bin überhaupt nicht
neidisch bin ich nicht ich habe hier die
Argumente gebracht ich habe hier die
Gründe gebracht dafür dass ich das
kritisieren darf dass die andere Person
diese Position bekommen hat oder dieses
gut bekommen hat ich bin nicht nackig nö
ich bin gerechtfertigt in meiner
Auffassung dass die andere Person diese
Position nicht bekommen hat wir kommen
gleich auf die Diskussion gerade wird
noch aufgezeichnet und wenn sie dann
gesagt bekommen du bist eine neidisch
oder ich das bekommen gesagt bekommen
bekäme dann wäre ich etwas empört dann
würde ich mich empören und würde mich
rechtfertigen würde meine Auffassung
rechtfertigt
und jetzt kann man sich wirklich fragen
ist der Neid Objektiv gerechtfert
objektiv und hier scheint mir ein
Problem der subjektiven Rechtfertigung
des Nades zu bestehen die neidische
Person kann sich nicht eingestehen dass
sie eine anderen Person in einer
Hinsicht unterlege ist
deswegen rationalisiert die neidische
Person die Situation so dass sie die
Überlegenheit der anderen Person bzw
ihre eigene Unterlegenheit oder Ohnmacht
und macht es auch ein Begriff der häufig
im Kontexten des Leides vorkommt
soeben rationalisiert das ist ungerecht
ist
deswegen ein in meinen Augen der Neid
eine Form von
anerkennungsverweigerung zu sein ich
persönlich bin der Meinung dass Neid
gerechtfertigt ist aus subjektiver Sicht
neidische Person rechtfertigen ihren
Neid aber objektiv ist dann halt nicht
gerechtfertigt und so erkläre ich mir
jetzt das Abstimmungsergebnis weil meine
Frage einfach auch ein bisschen vage
gestellt war bei Rechtfertigung immer
eine Rolle spielt nein nur ist der Neid
Objektiv gerechtfertigt also
gerechterweise gerechtfertigt oder nur
subjektiv weil eine Person eine andere
Person die Anerkennung verweigert
spricht weil sie nicht fair ist weil sie
keine fair playerin oder kein Pferd
Player ist ich würde die These Vertrieb
Neid ist keine Form von Fairplay
das Problem der Selbsttäuschung hängt
damit auch zusammen in meinen Augen mit
dem Begriff des Leides wir merken in der
Regel nicht dass wir neidisch sind wenn
wir gesagt bekommt du bist doch nur
neidisch weisen wir das von uns und
empören und sagen nein ich bin doch
nicht neidisch also wie kommst Du darauf
bist du nur gerecht so dass das ist
ungerecht das sind meine Argumente das
heißt wir täuschen uns im Neid selbst
über unsere Motive dass wir eigentlich
vielleicht sogar die andere Person
bewundern für Ihren Erfolg und diese
Bewunderung aber nicht eingestehen
wollen oder können und weil wir das
nicht können und daran auch leiden mit
dem nein sind häufig auch Gefühle des
Leidens verbunden besuchen wir das so zu
rationalisieren dass wir eben eine
subjektive Rechtfertigung anstrengend
und Gründe versuchen zu finden die die
andere Person in einem schlechteren
nicht da stehen lassen oder die um Ende
innerhalb deren die andere Person uns
vorgezogen wurden als ungerecht
klassifizieren und darüber diskutieren
wir jetzt